yeah the big righty a lot of postseason
experience last year this season 24
starts faced this brewers team back on
may 15th six innings two hits and an
earned run had a no hitter through six
innings that day
on the ground right side ozzy albies
one down in the first inning
anderson rears back and fires and a
swing and a miss
he struck him now
back to that curveball and that gets the
first strikeout into the column for ian
anderson 2-2 to garcia
got him
back-to-back strikeouts for ian anderson
frazier coming up
well don maybe the best pure stuff out
of the big three of them
obviously a lot younger
but you see 195 strikeouts pitched
against the braves back on may 16 six
innings only two hits no runs eight
caves an electric fastball winding and
pitching again breaking ball swinging a
miss
down on strikes
chopped off the plate waiting for it to
come down peralta and he goes
underhanded in time to get freddie
freeman
two down here in the first and aussie
albies
one for eight so far in the
series here
they shift on the right side against him
to right field
garcia moves over and will make the
catchy and right that ends the inning
coming over on july 6th
former che lifts it in the air to left
field rosario towards the line
and will make the catch in foul ground
popped up foul ground as anderson and
freeman both going over in late to kind
of react with his no but oh that ends up
in the seats and did you see who dropped
that ball is that chipper that is
chipper jones who just dropped the pop
fly it's a hall of famer right there
wow
that's an e5 oh poor larry that's gonna
be all over the place today that's an e5
yeah that is
i guess andrew jones next to him giving
him some lip service
one two
on the ground right side all these
ranges over two down
delivers swinging a tapper at the first
base line freeman comes in for picks it
up steps on first and ends the inning
one two duval
and this is the left and that's going to
dunk in for a base head
front of yelts the first two of reach
for atlanta in the second inning
to right field
garcia going back back peddling to the
dirt of the track to make the catch on
the edge of it tagging second moving to
third is riley and it's first and third
now with one down
darneau hits it in the air to left field
sending yelich back
he gets himself set will make the catch
here comes austin reilly
throw go to second and riley will
not score
before the out at second base
could not get in the out was recorded
first how about that a massive mistake
by adam deval at first base a little bit
quicker austin reilly was busting it
down there
and i know you're trying to be
aggressive but you know you have that
run
just let milwaukee out of a
trap popped up right around the bag at
second base all bees will make the catch
for round number one
swinging a miss pitch in the dirt
i don't know we'll have to throw him out
at first which he does and that is the
third strikeout for ian anderson on the
ground to first base freddie freeman
gobbles it up tags the bag inning over
here comes the 1-2 on the way to dansby
swanson
and a line drive caught by colton long
had him played perfectly in the shift
right behind the second base bag and
dansby swanson lines out to second base
lead on that and he strikes out that's
the second strikeout for peralta two
down in the inning
freeman offered and they'll tag him out
for strike three that's the third
strikeout for peralta
shift in the infield
struck him out came back to get him
strikeout number four for ian anderson
one down in the fourth inning
it's nine in a row set down as yellow
strikes one the other way for a base hit
shot it right through the opening
between riley and swanson and 02 garcia
got him
five strikeouts for ian anderson two
down in the fourth inning
second two out pitched by anderson swung
on missed he struck him out
change up
setting up away is narvaez
and eo1 pitch he's hit in the air right
center field long one for kane still
going warning track wall it is
off the wall off kane he goes down
they've all streaking around second he's
going to third and he will hold their
standing and they will run out to check
on the veteran lorenzo kane
he's one tough yeah i'll tell you that
stay in this game and the brave fans
giving him a hand
and he elevates to strike him out they
leave duvall at third base for the
brewers here in the fifth inning a 3-2
to left field and that is a fair ball
heading over is rosario to dig it out
heading for third is zurias going to
second with a double is narvaez and it's
second and third with nobody out but
halfway on the left side all the way in
on the right side and this is to the
diving shortstop swanson
he gets up throws out kane at first base
runners don't advance brewers instead of
having freddie peralta come to the plate
here or run a scoring chance they're
gonna try and play some runs
vogelback grounds one to third riley's
coming home and
got him in the rundown right now
headed back and aureus will be tagged
out
unable to advance that other runner from
second to third and that is out number
two
lined and caught by freddie freeman at
first base out of the jam is ian
anderson
trying to decide whether you stick with
ian anderson a little longer or go ahead
and use your spot on the batting order
for jack peterson i hope he went out
there to remind him that he took him
deep last time whatever you do don't
throw him that pitch thomas the
shortstop pretty near the bag at second
one two comes and it's hitting the air
to right field that one's gonna chance
to go she's gone
[Music]
john peterson a monster
post-season player jack peterson comes
through again it's a three-run homer it
is three to nothing atlanta let's go
look at jack peterson's home run back in
the bottom of the fifth look who's bat
he's using don anthony rizzo former
teammate with the gloves
walking slowly up to the right-hand
banners box is lorenzo kane
got him kane strikes out
the stretch now the pitch
swing looping line drive may sit to
center
peterson's going to go to third and
he'll make it very easily
and this is back up the middle swanson
the shortstop touches second fires to
first it's a double play
and the new pitcher the closer will
smith
man will smith with his first seat the
first postseason save in game two
liner caught at third by riley
goes up into the air to make the grab at
third for out number one in the ninth
inning
time to leave perfectly
the escobar went around and strikes out
two down in the ninth inning and the one
swinging a pop-up
right center shallow angling in duvall
called off by heredia they almost
collide duvall makes the catch and the
braves have taken a two games to one
advantage in the nlds
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes